All right, everyone, welcome back.
In our last exciting episode,
we learned how to take a string or a sentence
and use lexical analysis to break it down into a list of tokens or words.
And lexical analysis was based on our old best friends regular expressions.
And remember that we need to break down HTML or JavaScript source code
into tokens and then into valid utterances
in order to understand them and build our web browser.
However, it turns out that just having a list of tokens
or a list of words is not enough.
We can still be confused.
For example, I've written here 2 collections of words.
The first, "Simone de Beauvoir wrote 'The Mandarins,'"
and the second, "wrote wrote Simone de de de."
Even though this second collection of words
uses only words that occur in the first,
we like this one, and this one makes us very confused,
so just a list of words isn't enough.
They have to adhere to a valid structure.
There's a subject and a verb and an object,
and down here in bag of words 2,
it's not really clear what's going on.
In particular, we're tempted to say that bag of words #1,
"Simone de Beauvoir wrote 'The Mandarins,'" follows English grammar,
follows the rules of how we construct sentences or thoughts in English,
and the second does not.
The grammar for any modern natural language, be it Mandarin Chinese,
English, French, admits an infinite number of utterances.
But not--and this is super critical--not all utterances,
all interesting grammars, rule something out.
Provide structure by saying that you can't say gibberish.
You have to say something meaningful.
Despite the fact that we're going to rule out quite a few bags of words,
we're still going to have plenty of room for creativity, and you'll see how in just a minute.